is sex really about power so what's the
role of power dynamics in sex
with everything you understand like in
from the survey in terms of what people
are turned on by you've talked about
like the preferences that women versus
men have for like submissiveness and
dominance
and uh we've already talked about it a
little bit but like it's expressed more
strongly see I already forget the
results but I feel like women have more
preference to be submissive yeah this is
one of the things that got me into
researching fetches to begin with
because I think I came across some date
I did like a brief survey where about
roughly around 60 of women report being
submissive and 40 of men report being
nominant and this was really fascinating
to me like why is there this Gap like
why why do we not because I guess I have
some priors that maybe this is an
evolutionary thing like the submission
dominant like strong men and you know
like women would be like us hot hot man
you know the men are like ravaging and
stuff I'm like shouldn't this be a in
our genes but but there's a gap
what's the Gap the Gap is the dominant
submissive Gap more women are submissive
than there are dominant men oh yeah wait
really yeah it's a pretty significant
Gap and this is held up like it depends
on what you're testing I've tested a
bunch of things this is part of why I
did this big survey nice but it depends
against again on like what kind of
dominance you're measuring but overall
it's a roughly 40 to 60 So when you say
there's not many dominant men
then the meaning like they express like
a desire to be dominant in a
relationship yeah or like in sexually
sexually sexually in bed so like if I
ask questions like how much do you like
being dominant in bed like men are less
likely to answer strong yes to that
question but if I ask are you likely to
be submissive like women are very much
yes
really and that's expressive like that's
that that that that represents truth
um my guess what's wrong with men so
this is I think there's some reflection
like FetLife so fat life is this website
where people like sign up and connect
based on their fetishes and this is like
you can kind of see it picked up in the
Forum post about like how like dominant
men are you know are getting laid so
much and you know submissives are always
looking for a dominant like there's it's
an unequal Market holy yeah this is
great news
know this that's interesting yeah so
what does it reflect about modern
society is that like uh is that because
you know there's these Trends about like
decreased masculinity or that yeah so is
that right is that similar I'm trying
not to hold on to one Theory because I'm
not sure one is possible like decreasing
testosterone levels
um testosterone seems to be I have a
little bit of other research but I'm
still checking it out that seems to
indicate that uh higher testosterone
you're more likely to be dominant so if
we're seeing decreased testosterone
levels across Society where it should be
seeing a greater uh Gap
um this is so fascinating once again
this is like a super interesting way to
look at Humanity because it is such an
important part of humanity and so like
how many people are doing large-scale
research like this I feel like you're
like at the top of the world you're like
world class at the top of the world
doing research on this stuff yeah I
think I might have the biggest most
comprehensive fetish data set in the
world right now
that's epic thank you I'm really happy
about it I'm very proud yeah and it's
you know it's it's probably growing but
it's also enabling you to establish a
name to where you like a Prestige like a
reputation to where people can go to you
to like trust you more and more to do
longer surveys perhaps
like yeah maybe I think people it's the
date the data analysis afterwards is
very different from like the survey
design itself
so I'm still very amateur at the data
analysis yeah but you can always catch
up on that I guess the data analysis
does enable you to does teach you how to
ask better questions in order yes it
goes back and forth like as I'm looking
at the data it informs the way I want to
phrase questions the next time so women
are more at least in private able to uh
say that they would like to be
submissive and Men even in private are
not
disproportionately saying they're not
willing to be dominant
yeah so it's possible if this is caused
by decreasing testosterone levels and
this means that we're probably having
less satisfying sex overall like we're
becoming less and less sexually
compatible as time goes on to be fair
I'm not sure that it is connected to
testosterone levels like it's possible
that this is just like a genetic thing
like me the gay Uncle Theory like the
idea is like maybe gay people evolve to
like be sort of taking themselves out of
the gene pool to be us but to be
assistants and like it's possible that
like there's a certain percentage of men
sort of like quote unquote evolved to be
submissive to take themselves out of
sexual competition and to instead be
like the the monkeys revolving at the
edge of the pack oh it's a method of
survival like so you stay out of the
competition yeah and I'm like a little
obsessed about these kinds of Evo psych
theories so I'm not I'm just saying it
because it's like there's different
ideas that are possible yeah okay so
yeah I'm not saying it's definitely
testosterone there's other things it's
also possible that it's culture people
are definitely gonna bring that up based
on my survey though it doesn't seem to
be any evidence of that like I asked
about uh like how much pressure was put
on you to be you know agenty in your
childhood like a lot of questions around
this kind of thing and no correlation at
all to dominance